all right so welcome to the cs9 final
review session um my name is
will thank um I'm w t uh I'll be leading
the the section so first up here's a
here's CS 109 the general advice usually
we want usually students focus on how to
like apply formulas from class maybe try
to get a numerical answer and the these
are done these are like okay so one
example how to take a derivative from an
mle like okay that's actually kind of
like that's quite challenging but also
like once you know how to take a
derivative it's pretty straightforward
to take a derivative the hard part is
usually like the modeling so like log
likely like actually finding the
distribution for a log likelihood if we
don't tell you so on that note
especially for the final if for those
for those of you that have seen the
practice finals there is a lot of
reading like every single problem has
like two three paragraphs of just like
straight context and then like three
bullet point questions that come right
after it so in the same sense the final
the midterm exam had like six questions
or five or five questions or so with
like very small like amount of reading
and like a lot of problem solving on the
final similar number of problems a lot
more reading and expect a few more parts
okay so please read the problems very
thoroughly and then like the problem
should be like
doable
okay all
right so here's how to read probability
in defund the final exam Edition so to
make this slide I kind of went through
the first final that I saw and just took
a look at okay like what's the most
common Paradigm that we saw what the
most common amount amount of words by
the way these slides will be posted
later um so the first thing so first
things are like what's a prob what's the
probability of blank this is like in
like three out of like or at least one
of the sub parts on most of the problems
I've seen how much more likely and then
okay so in that case you want to write a
probability of something a very common
one we also see is like how much more
likely is a blink than a blink usually
this means you want to you want to be
dividing two
likelihoods or PDFs or probably or like
products of of PDFs in like this in the
discret case this would be like the like
two probabilities and you'll be dividing
them okay so we also see the word yes
you mean by likelihoods oh likelihood is
like like the product of like of like a
PDF so like uh P4 problem 7 there was a
okay maybe I should explain what that is
it's uh just dis
thing boy your likelihood is like this
like you're just uh
like as some point in time in one of
your pieas you had something that looked
like
this right or I guess it wasn't Theta at
this point it was like a x given B it
was a and x given B right I have to like
Duck my head down I to use microphone
so that's what I mean by likelihood like
this is technically like a this is kind
of like a like a form of likelihood
okay all
right if we say the word
parameterize and don't and don't specify
the method which we probably will
specify the method it usually means
you're going to do one of mle or map and
if you're going to be doing mle or map
find the data like find what your what
Your sums or what your products are over
especially like I think on the on like
the last section we had a problem about
like start about setting up like a bobo
place on campus there was a hidden data
point in there somewhere that they you
had do mle4 it was a single data point
so that could
happen Okay um if we say approximate so
during the midterm approximate just
means use a gausian or person
approximation and on the final all that
means is if you see a set of random
variables go hand just use
CLT okay that's usually what
approximation means here by the way cave
if you CLT make sure the continuity
correct continuity correct is everywhere
I did not put them in in the slides
because that's kind of like a thing we
cover cover before the midterm but like
remember to do that here
too um is blank significant uh usually
that means like a bootstrap or like a P
value so typically like write write an
algo or like uh show like hey like count
some things to be like hey the P value
is like greater than 5% uh probably not
probably not good as so
okay all right so with that we start our
journey with betas betas are the first
things that we saw that were like
clearly post midterm material and in a
beta the way the dist the the beta
distribution is set up like with two
parameters A and B and they represent a
minus one heads and B minus one Tails
from like a bias coin y so betas are
always typically over like typically
characterize our belief over a beri and
they represent the prob the probability
of a beri parameter given like certain
amount of heads and a certain amount of
Tails okay um there the betas are in the
range zero and one they have some they
have a form of a PDF with some parameter
with some like constant B that that is
like that we we write explicitly later
the important parts are the expectation
and the variance so these are the two
these are the these like two values that
I saw come up in like one of the
practice exams I have an example on this
like the end the size so we we'll take a
look at it more but generally the reason
why we put beta distribution after the
midterm and in its own thing is because
the beta the beta distribution actually
like it captures something about the
parameters of a brunoli like before we
just had like Beres or like just like um
binomials about like random events now
we're like okay what's the pro what's
like the r what's the probability of
like of a particular Theta in like
AI
okay all right then we talked about
adding independent variables so the
three most heavily used forms I've seen
of adding Rand random variables are like
pan adding pons adding normals adding
binomials they all have to be like kind
of they all have to be like IID like so
so like if they're independent of each
of each other and they're from the same
pant distribution and you sum them you
can like that's like just like Su suming
to the L suming to the lambas K uh one
particular example of this is like in
evg there's three elevators if both of
the the other elevators are are out of
service what the the the amount of
people that are going to be trying to
trying to go into an elevator on or
they're going to be trying to go into
the last remaining elevator will be
three times Lambda assuming each one of
the each one of the elevators is like
has a plus of Lambda for students trying
to use it
okay um the normal distribution so okay
when you add normal distributions you
want to be adding variances you don't
want to be adding standard deviations so
that's why we put the sigma squares over
here so St like if you have two r two
like normals you add add the mean add
the variance and then like one
particular example of this is like okay
like heights are typically normally
distributed so if you had like people
like sitting piggyback on top of each
other that's like the sum of two Cs on
on on the height yeah it just literally
taller um and the final one is on
binomials so binomials is like if you
have like when I think of binomial I
think of like trials and I think of like
a b of like some underlying like bruli
event like I have a coin I'm trying to
flip it I'm trying to get how many
however many heads or however many Tails
so one way to think one example to think
about like binomials is you and a
co-author are conducting the same
experiment right and and then but you
ran you like ran N1 trials and your
co-author ran N2 trials like
independently of each other like what is
the probability distribution of like
your results from those from like if you
like coales the two the two sets of
Trials together and the solution is well
like just add the so you just increased
the number of Trials you didn't change
anything about the underlying parameter
so you're just going to have have a
binomial of like number of trials for
one plus number of trials for the second
one okay so this is adding independent
random variables
yes previous slide there's a constant FR
of the data distribution yeah what does
that mean uh that's not a course reader
it's some complicated
number yeah like we have it in the sides
but like I I just yeah it's a constant
like you can normalize it out usually
yes we need to know that constant for
the fin we'll probably give it to you if
you need it honestly but real answer you
got 10 pages of of riew sheets just
sticking like the margin of one of
them okay all right any other ones no
okay so here's a central limit theorem
um there's two there's kind of two
flavors of the central limit theorem you
could take the sum of i x IID random
variables or you could take the average
of some IID random variables one example
of some IID random variables is give
enough trials anything looks like a
normal so so if I so like those like
that that little graph like if I just
keep rolling dice the sum that I'm going
to get from those dice it's going to
eventually look like a normal and that's
like the approximation that we're going
to use um average of IID variables they
these actually these actually are used a
lot in the noising so like if you like
the one example like sample means are
normally distributed so like the bigger
your sample mean the more the more the
less variance of those kinds of means
that you will see so like the better so
that's like like a tight like a tighter
average that you would
find okay make sense these are so this
is like one of the critical theorems
that we use and we actually given it a
name okay all right so next thing that
we have is sampling so in sampling we
actually saw how to use the how to find
the sample mean the sample standard
deviation and typically whenever we
sample the image I have in my head or
the one that we have from the class is
that here's some underline distribution
you construct some like like sample
histogram and then each one of these
points becomes an equivalent class of
that kind of point so that would be
important later on in bootstrapping but
just know that you're like trying to
construct something that looks similar
to what your underlying distribution F
looks like okay um so sample mean and
Sample variance are two particular
quantities that we can talk about uh
they are unbiased meaning that the
expected value of all of the sample
means that we could possibly take is
actually going to be the mean and the
expectation of like all the sample
variances should actually come out to be
the sample sorry should actually
converge to the
variance
okay all right makes sense looks good
okay so then we took an interlude and
started talking about algorithmic
analysis I put boost I put bootstrapping
after this I promise um so there was uh
there was some want about how to do
about like an actually another example
of of algorithmic analysis stepping
through it step by by
step okay and the way so I conjured up
another example of recurse so I took the
rec curse from lecture and then I like
made it a little bit more more
complicated by adding in this like
random variable q and some like and the
for Loop that like actually increments
based on what whatever Q is this should
look like problem nine from pet six no
from pet five yeah so this is the one
where like okay like we actually need to
show that like Q is independent of
something all right so here's a lot
total expectation and the prompt that
we're given is okay what is the expected
return value of this recurse function
okay so how do we start this usually all
right our Target is expectation of X so
random variable call call the function
signature the
expectation then we replace recursive
function signature with the expectation
of X everywhere we see it and it matches
like ver verbatim okay so here we'll
return the the we replace the recurse on
the return statement with 7 plus
expectation of X okay now where it gets
complicated is in the for Loop here we
technically have expectation of x times
Q where Q is this is this other like
uniform distribution here from or from
from Q okay so the way we the way we
work with that is what we see that
whatever our choice Q is here is going
to be independent of whatever this
recurse is going to return us so we can
just make the the independent something
here and say that expectation of x * Q
is equal to the expectation of X time
the expectation of Q
okay so after that okay return three
three is three so no expectation here
it's just this all right
yes oh sure so in the for Loop here the
value that we're going to turny here is
like okay depending on whatever Q it
like the random the random variable here
is like big Q and then the random
variable that we're going to get out of
recurse at every step is some X right so
that so when you have two random
variables and we're looking for like
like how many like they're independent
of each other and you're trying to
multiply them so like first you'll say
okay the two round events multiply each
other and then you say and then you say
okay they're actually independent of
each other so you can just split up the
expectation here by Independence
assumption there is one thing that's
kind of tricky here is that like one
question is like okay is Q like if we
were to think about this outer e of X is
Q independent of this outer e ofx or
sorry let me let me put it the the other
way is the outer e of X here independent
of Q the answer is no
but the the the trick here is that the
inner recurse has like another random
variable X this is not actually the
original X that we had at the outer
scope of the function it's the one from
the inner scope of the function meaning
that this should be like x i or
something drawn from the same
distribution as this X over here okay so
that was one thing that that kind of
came up a few times on an ad post but
should should be
reasonable okay does that make sense to
everyone all right so plug in three okay
now we just put it all together and do
some math so we multiply each one of the
branches by their by their expected
value so we take we use the law of total
expectation um the probability of
entering this first Branch with seven
plus recurse is one out of these 10 so
that's one tenth the probability of
entering like one like the recurse here
is one out of is another one out of 10
so that's this term right here then 8/1
of the time we return three the reason
why I chose 1/10th 11/10 and 8/10 is
because if I made it any bigger the the
expectation is actually in infinite and
when it's infinite we can't really apply
the law total total expectation but
that's a that's a detail okay so now we
just start so now we just start
summing so Sumit we just okay we
distribute that you got 10 expectation
on the left six six expectations on the
right and 31 clict the terms and solve
and you get 31 over
four did I make sense should I like go
through that a little slower
or we
could
okay yes be 37 over 9 oh no never mind I
multi sorry my bet okay cool I mean I
would not be surprised if there was a
typo in this this was this was written
late at night I didn't see the
multiplications
okay all
right
so now this
bootstrapping so when we visited
bootstrapping it was from sampling um we
cared about two values when we were
doing sampling and it was the sample
mean and the sample variance that means
our two flavors of bootstrapping are
going to be over means and over
variances so what that means is whenever
you so the typical bootstrapping
actually I have a good example of this I
can like just have know this know the
structure for boost strapping of means
and boost strapping of variances the key
difference is you'll be like calculating
a mean on the res sample and then you
have a distribution of your means on the
variance version you have a variance of
your resample and and then you have the
distribution of your variances these are
the two most common forms of like poping
that we're going to throw throw at you
in this class and I'll run so here is a
here's an example of like how to do of
like the the Corgi problem that you guys
saw in section so I realized that the
Corgi solution that we had on the the
website actually has really like jumbled
up like lot like over Leaf so we I took
the stat solution we like just and just
like like M example out of it so here's
what we're going to state is there's two
islands with the corgis we want to say
that Island B Corgis have a 3inch higher
variance than the height of those in a
okay so if we look at the heights of the
corgis in Islands A and B Island we want
to assert to claim that Island B's
variance is higher by three okay
the way we do that is okay here's the
population of all the corgis we draw
population one from the island of corgis
and Island a and we draw a population oh
that's supposed to be two great there's
a typo population two is supposed to be
from from corat of
B okay and then we start and then we we
like combine them into like a general
population and start resampling so the
way we start there is okay so this boo
part is the execution of the code so we
first create the total population of all
the quiries
then we enter a for Loop and we say okay
so repeat the following 50 times notice
that we only repeat resampling from the
total population and not resampling from
like all from like the space of all
Corgis or from like islands like a good
way to know this is like uh like your
your researchers have already left the
island so they can't really go back to
take more corgis right we could only
have so many
corgis so okay so repeat 50
times and
then the the first thing we do is we
resign sample two samples from the total
population and then once we resample the
the two samples from the total
population is okay this this part is
going to going to be fast we're going to
five lines of cod coding one we take the
count so we look at we look at the
difference between the S the sample
variance of Island 2 minus Island one
and we look at the at the difference if
this difference is greater than three we
just increment by one so that's exactly
what the sign is saying and one here
here is the indicated random variable
that says okay if this is if this like
random event so happens to be true we'll
increment one into the
count okay does that help like any
questions um yes this is this is an
example of a problem will be calculating
P value um
maybe one of the other ones like that we
saw before like calculating me where
rather than combining two populations
that we just have like one some
population like like in the in the mean
happiness example from like all we all
we did was just have like a subsection
of the population like we didn't like
take two and then recombine them oh yeah
I didn't put that in the I didn't put
that in the examples because that was a
lecture example already so I was
thinking like I was trying to give some
something that wasn't like that was like
not too far from the from the lecture
but still wasn't like completely totally
like redundant so like could we
potentially see both of those types of
problems
but also like if we give you guys a
boost ding problem right we're not going
to go give you like a giant list and say
okay take a sum over all these that's
not a like I'm most will say hey here's
like like like two or three samples yes
in the back um why are you taking the
absolute value of that difference when
you want to show that Island B so like
sample two has a higher oh it's because
we want to see okay like we want to see
if we take the take the the coris from
from Island a and Island B and put them
into a to into like a total population
we don't actually know like which one of
these corg came from Island a and Island
B and what our P value is trying to show
is hey even if I don't know like there
shouldn't like the the claim about the
variance shouldn't just appear in nature
like it shouldn't just appear if I just
like randomly like combine these two
these two samples and then just started
taking like resamples so like the idea
is like if like population a has like
like if we combine population a and
population B and we just suddenly start
seeing oh yeah there's like differences
in like fa in like
the variance is like greater than three
just like
in like in general then the claim is
probably not good so that would actually
give us like a higher P value so like
the higher the P value is higher in the
probability that a hypothesis is
null does that kind of explain it or
okay I think I was just a little
confused because like sample two would
be a different size and variance is also
dependent on the SLE but so you should
always take the absolute value of the
difference um
uh one testest
yeah yeah okay uh you have a okay as for
what if your said if you have a two tail
test take the absolute
value okay two tail what is it do we
need to talk okay um we can talk about
this offline I gu yeah clarified offline
but but in general like if like if you
have a total population here right and
you like try to split into two samples
and you take the take the difference
right like you don't you don't know if
you're proving that they're small
by three or bigger than three so like
keep the
like short answer is yes but be cautious
about it don't
okay the problem will probably tell you
if you should should take the absolute
value or not okay all
right where do we get the three
from oh three three inches higher higher
yeah it was it was an a prompt yes
is there a um time you would ever sample
without
rep that's called a per that's called a
permutation test and no yes okay all
right next all right parameter
estimation okay so very uh very this is
a very old meme according to my
associates um so in parameter
estimation you have the the the problem
will tell will probably ask you what do
we want and you'll say ah we want the
parameters and what do they look like
some Greek symbols or P or A and B and
these are so these are given to you like
okay if you have a bruli your Theta is
going to be a p if you have a pan Lambda
your Theta is going to be a Lambda if
you have uniform A and B your thetas are
going to be a and b and you have normal
going mu and mu and sigma square right
so question is like okay why why why is
Thea the only one that's like left
isolated here is because we will
conventionally like the first Greek
letter we we think of whenever we think
of parameters is Theta probably because
it's EAS to write or something so so
yeah so this is parameter
estimation
okay all right then here's maximum
likelihood estimators so whenever I
think of mle I think of like a two-step
process uh step Pro like the first step
is to find the likelihood the second
step is to optimize it so likelihood
here is a big product over all over all
the PDFs um usually you want the log
likelihood because you want to take a
derivative of it and then once we find
the derivative we can actually solve for
the arcmax of the Theta so to solve for
arcmax of the Theta here you would
either use gradient Ascent or you will
set the derivative equal to zero and
solve we will most likely tip you off
about which one you should be using on a
problem so so so you don't like spend
too much time trying to solve for zero
on like a or trying to solve derivative
equals zero on a problem where we should
be using gradient descent and typically
those forms are like describe an
algorithm I I should have put this in
the English part like if a problem says
describe an algorithm to optimize you
almost always want to go to gradient
descent if the problem doesn't say that
there is a chance that you could solve
it using the using the idea that the
derivative should should be equal to
zero
okay make
sense all
right so here's map what's the
difference between map and mle right so
what I wrote here was I put the two
steps of the map on the left and I put
the two steps of the map on the right so
ml is on the left map's on the right or
I should have labeled these a little bit
better so in mle I'll up I'll update
these Sid I you say that like this there
should be like an mle here in the left
side over here you just have the PDF on
the right side in the map you have some
prior G of theta here we will almost
always give you what this Theta is and
the only point is it's multiplied so the
opop so the okay I put a big space here
but these are actually multiplied by
each other and you want to you want to
find the optimal parameter like the
arcmax of this likely where they
actually multiply by each other okay um
the main difference is here in your ARG
Max function you will have a log of the
G of theta added to your original like
Arc Max Target for mle okay so I mean
like just just for exposition go back
one like you're here just taking the
argmax over like this
product or or over this
sum and here you're taking the arax over
like that sum and the
log okay
that's the main difference yes so the
right is the map yes the right side is
the map yeah I should yeah I had labels
on these but then I think they got they
they got shifted around when I was
trying to like squeeze in the map yes
the key difference is that an map
includes a prior G yes so the map is
like if you had a friend that did that
that has already done some
experimentation on this and you want to
use their
work okay yes then by virtue of that map
would be slightly more accurate than mle
if you if your friend is a good friend
and gave and gave you correct data
that's not noisy which is I mean good
friends could accidentally give you like
that data too but is that why mle is
just more common then mle is like you
need Emily to solve map so we like
introduce Emily first and then map why
it's more common it probably is more
common but I'm not quite sure I I don't
actually know the general claim of that
yes will the problem tell us like
whether when you use M or M or will that
be given like if it gives you a prior
that's tip off right it gives you a
prior you should probably use the prior
yeah
okay all righty so next one is here are
MP priors I put this slide on here just
for exposition but we will almost always
give you these but the idea is like
whatever whatever your post whatever
your like full your like mle estimate is
this will actually influence what your
prior should be so if you're like
estimated is like a beri you want to all
almost always use a beta to be your
prior and these are like the whole
conjugate distribution things so like
you guys don't have to know like every
little detail about conjugate
distributions because will almost always
give you whatever prior this is here and
all you guys need to know is how to use
it in the ml in the map
sense okay I mean cheat cheat sheet wise
you have 10 pages if you want like just
write down the names of these of these
distributions and their parameters and
maybe like a one sentence about like
what they do or like I don't know while
on like a bike rider or something and
you're waiting for like a parking spot
just like whip out a phone and like
check it who knows
okay all right so that's about map
priors so here's the the general machine
learning Paradigm the idea is someone
someone gives you data and they want the
optimal parameter because it's totally a
fair trade oh yes sorry
sure before you start trading okay um
for the What is
the
the D is a is the conjugate prior of the
multinomial
so you know what look at the course
reader they'll probably tell
you look at the course reader we have a
description of it it if you have to use
a d State we'll give you the parameters
for it
okay sounds good yeah let's go let's go
let's go Trace some parameters for
datas all right so here so in machine
learning typically you have is some real
world problem you want to model and then
you want to model the problem and format
and use sorry using a formal model Theta
here is typically where you would find
like log
likelihood and then you will have some
training data so this is the this is the
indices on your sum and then you have
some learning algorithm and this
learning algorithm is usually like how
however how you optimize the Theta okay
and then since we're all veterans on P
set 6 by now here is the testing data
and you're supposed to just get a score
after after you get out this optimal
parameter so just a brief high level
about like how about how the machine
learning things work um we might ask you
like a true false question about about
like some about like some parts of the
data pipeline but we're not going to get
give you like a 30 pointer on just hey
design this design a machine learning
model for this like that's a that's a
little uh that's a little hard
okay all right so after that we saw
naive base um naive Bas is just using
the independence assumption where like
if you if I condition on a y then all
the X I are independent it's naive
because we're trying to condition on the
independence
so what's special about so what's the
hard hard Parts about the naive Bas is
we're trying so we're trying to like
we're we're given these like two PS of
like x i and y and we're trying to
actually predict like okay what's the
optimal y here of G given the given
these LA
right and the thing that you typically
want to do is Ave smoothing which means
Okay add one to all your numerators and
then add two or however many to your
denominators so so that the data set is
still
balanced and usually this is just like a
counting problem where like okay you
just count the number of times where x i
equals x i and Big Y equals little Y and
you divide it by like the samples were
like Y is equal to little
y okay and then when you do do a
prediction no need to do a derivative
here no need to do like any gr Ascent
nothing nothing of that sort just Loop
over all your all your y's look at your
data do a few sums spit it out that's
that's naive
base okay yes can you explain what P hat
me P
hat oh P hat is actually is the prob is
the probability that is a probability
that we're like our estimated
probability that Y is the actual
y yes that we're going to try to that
we're going to try to like drive here so
p p hat is like our our estimate of like
whatever the XI equal of like the XI and
Y
okay so this this is the thing that we
actually find in
training yes it's the approximate
whenever you see a hat it's approximate
okay yes um is the probability of Y uh
being
oneus
zero sorry one sorry why right you plug
in zero for y sure right uh it's one
minus that yeah probability that y has
is
one prob that y had conjug uh that's if
Y is a br that's if Y is a broli if it's
zero one y can be four cost four right
like it could be like happy face SMY
face uh sad face and angry phas right it
could be it could be like size four
right yeah yeah like if Y is a br yeah
you can do one minus but if it's not
then so so in this case Zero or
one yeah in this case yeah because
because of 01 yeah like it exp says like
okay all right so next here's logistic
regression logistic regression in my
opinion is like ml with a berol but the
thing about a bruli is it had it's a
discrete random variable so we had to
like go conjure up a PDF with a
bruli okay so the so that and that's
where we get the inspiration for like
the for like the log like
likelihood yes could you explain how mle
and map fit into like naive phase and um
regression like one more time so I can
explain how ml fits in the logistic
regression because it's just logistic
regression where your PDF or your
likelihood function is chosen with the
PDF of a br distribution for
map like map is like what happens if you
have like a prior but in naive B like
okay so map to logistic regression you
can have logistic regression problem
that is Sol that is like solvable using
like map so like if I give you a prior
about if I give you a prior about this
beri right it's going to take the form
of a beta then you can Sol then you you
just have have another like data point
for your dat for your like prediction
algorithm um how naive Bay fits in is a
little bit more tricky because naive Bas
doesn't like naive base you're just
you're taking the independence
assumption and you're just counting like
I don't know I think yeah so there like
midd parameter
estimation just PE hat like you're
you're your parameter estimation is
honestly done online so like it's kind
of like you don't like you have to Loop
over your whole data set every single
time you you want to do a you want to do
a prediction which is like that's like
the key difference between like mle and
like uh like naive base
right okay all right
good all right so with that I have a
bunch of problems lined up or two or
three something I think it's like two or
three yeah and uh I I'll walk through
them slowly they're not going to be like
that boost Drive example example where
there was like four lines worth of like
problems but sorry no four lines worth
of code then in one then in one comment
that won't happen but so here's the
problems so the first one is an mle
example it's about how to do do
reliability engineering and here's a
problem where you say okay we have a
random variable characterized by a with
some PDF this and we wish to know how
long a particular model of of a phone
will function before it breaks that's
what this PDF is here we are going to
use a reliability a reliability
distribution to this end we collect n
independent measurements of how long the
type of phone functions before it breaks
X1 through xn explaining words how you
would choose parameter a using the mle
framework and provide any necessary
derivatives okay so what's what's the
key what are the key data points here
what's our parameter a where's our data
set X1 through xn what which algorithm
are we using mle what's what's our
likelihood this thing right here the the
center this like big equation so how do
we map this to our
two-step we draw arrows and say okay the
the F just replaces like strictly with
with ourf take the data points X1
through xn and repl and replace x i with
them Theta Theta hat here and normal
Theta here replace that with parameter a
and then we apply the mle like like the
like a training we apply the estimator
from the
mle okay so to that end I wrote out all
the steps we're going to move the
problem up the upper right and I hope
that's not too small keep on our back
are we good is okay so first we find the
like we need to find a log likelihood so
we we're we're given the likelihood
first so we take the log yeah we just
apply the log and put an L on the
left then we swap the log and the
product so it becomes the sum over the
log is it is it is it too small is that
okay that's x squ j and and this is x
squ j and a and a
squ and then we use some more lo we use
log rules and and start splitting up the
terms so this is just like mult if you
have like multiplication in your log
they're like
added use log rules again to bring your
exponents down okay now you have like
this fully like almost simplified like
summation
term and then just break up the sums a
little a little bit so it's easier to do
the derivatives
okay okay and then like okay take take
out a few terms like uh you like use
like there's no this term right here
does not rely on I at all so you can
just sum over sum over all n of them and
that's two -2 n okay any questions about
how we went from like log from like
likelihood to log
likelihood assuming the text is not too
small for people in back to see I
realize that this might be this this
might be a little this might be a bit
small but the slides have have all the
numbers first yes
simpi I mean sufficiently simplified to
to to take a derivative yeah I mean this
is super simplifi we're also not going
to like be like hey how much do you
simplify your log likelihood it just has
to be simple enough to can actually take
a derivative in like a reasonable way
okay all right so now we take the
derivative so step two
optimize so to optimize we need to
optimize with respect to our parameter
a so that's just okay take the
derivative of this of this giant thing
down
here and then if we apply the derivative
to each one of these terms we see okay
this becomes like -2 a this becomes like
uh just log of XI this becomes that this
becomes nothing because it's just
there's no a term here and this is like
positive 1 over a cub or so something of
that
sort and if you propagate the derivative
simplify you get just those just those
those terms that we
saw yes so this a so so this is these
are not the these are not the same not
the same terms because we we dropped the
a from this term about here okay so then
I think at this point yeah you set the
derivative equal to zero and you can
solve for a so one way that you can know
that you can solve for a here is that
there's only one parameter like we saw
in a section problem where there was
like a where there was like two
parameters like get both like mu and
sigma but here you only have a you
should be able to solve for it if you
don't that's probably okay yes have two
parameters you're trying to optimize
take the
partial with respect to both parameters
optimize that yes and then so then in
that case you would have like two
partial derivatives right you would have
like uh well you know what here we only
had
[Music]
like partial l l over partial a right in
that case it me does not look like a in
that particular case you would have like
partial LL over partial mu and partial
LL so you have like this thing and like
and then like comma partial LL over
partial
Sigma and then so you'll take the
derivative of both of those and try to
optimize usually if you have two
parameters so you need to optimize for
we don't expect you guys to solve
setting it equal to zero and you will
just use gradient Ascent yes now can you
optimize both the MU and the sigma
independently one will become a one will
become so if you can solve for one
parameter in terms of the other one then
yes but if you can't like if if Sigma is
dependent on moo and then moo is also
dependent on Sigma then it's not so
simple and you need to use it and you
need to use a scent
yes the Su terms in the middle oh the
sum terms in in in the middle are you
talking about this term uh so this one
we're taking the derivative with respect
to a so take your partial derivative
pass it into oh here I have this I have
a ho laser pointer so we take this
partial derivative with respect to a
pass it into the sum and then you know
that like sum and like the partial
derivative I can just pass the partial
derivative into the
sum then just take okay partial
derivative of a Time log of x i is just
log of XI which is this exact term we
have down
here okay and then this like this Su
term just disappears because there's no
a in there cool
yes first on on the last on the solution
we got -2 a a because of negative log of
a right yes so log a here just the
derivative here just because 1/ a * -2 n
yeah cool cool yes keep keep asking the
derivatives are hard we should we should
practice
them okay all
right
so yes oh sorry was oh um so for
optimization MLA and map will be mostly
stick with taking the partial setting
zero as gradi descent will mostly stay
in the realm of logistic
regression you could actually tell if
the problem wants to use gradient sent
or not sometimes if we we'll say at the
end give us like a three sentence
algorithm about like how to okay this is
also not a promise because like like I
we we haven't like we haven't decided
yet but like you you should like usually
at the end of a problem if it tells you
hey give us like a three like a like a
three sentence thing about how you would
optimize it that typically means you can
solve it by set by setting it equal to
zero but if we don't say anything you
might be able to solve it equal to zero
and might as in even if you make a
mistake along the way somewhere you can
always just fall back on gradient ascent
and we give some some partial credit for
that and we can just explain gradient
words oh uh I I have a side with
gradient Ascent right like uh oh it's
too far back but in the in the Sid there
is a gradient Ascent you can just be
like theeta new equals Theta old minus
partial derivative LL Theta done
right yeah could just write that be like
oh yeah I just execute this in a loop or
something yeah okay all right so here's
an example about how to use betas and
how to do pseudo code
so um let's say that we have observed
some 30 successes and 20 failures for an
event with unknown
probability uh based on this information
we can model the probability of success
X as a beta random variable we want to
make the claim of the form the
probability of success is M plus or
minus
B
okay so we need to select M here to be
the expectation of X select B to be the
smallest value rounded to two decimal
places such that probability of n minus
B is less than like X less than like M
plus b is greater than or equal to like
95% and provide your answer as a pseudo
code that prints out the values M andb
okay so here are some key points that I
had on the first pass of this problem
but looking at it again this morning
when I I didn't have time time to edit
the sides there another two so oh here
the Bolder part that I just forgot
didn't didn't box in rounded to two
decimal places okay what this typically
means is somewhere in your pseud code
you'll be doing a grid
search okay what does that mean that
means that if I'm after some value
like oh they're both used okay so if I'm
after some value
say x right I want like X
between
uh Like A and
B there should probably be like a for
Loop in
there that does like X plus equals like
0.01 because they say up to two decimal
places and you're just going to be
looping do do this until like
break break if if you have some
condition on
X okay so this is like a g search kind
of strategy where you're like okay like
you just want to like sweep over all the
possible values of X up to some
precision and it will return to the
value that that you
need
okay all right so for this particular
problem we have a starter function yes
because everything starts with Main and
then we we need to combine the 30 the 30
successes and 20 failures into a beta so
here the beta that that we need to
initialize is 30 is a beta with 30 + 1
and 20 + 1 plus one because we always on
in sorry initialize beta with an extra
one okay as per like normal like beta
initialization then we say okay they
want they want something of the form M
so we know that the M here is the
expectation of X so we use the second
Point here for like finding what the
expectation of like what the beta
is
okay then now okay so how do we so how
do we find X like we we're given that it
has be accurate of like two decimal
places and it has to be within this
particular range it has to be greater
than like 0.995
right so what we do that is in a in a
four Loop okay so here's what I'm
supposed to say just just increment it
slowly and the way we do it is here's a
while true so in the while
true so here's the loop that that
actually does a gri search approach we
want to say that okay X has to be
greater greater than like the lower
bound which is just the mean minus X but
it has to be like less than like the
upper bound which is mean plus X and
then the probability of that of that
region is the CDF of whatever the upper
side is minus the CD of of whatever the
Lower Side is and if that's greater than
95% which is which is our Target then we
break it otherwise we continue on with a
grid search okay and then just print it
out and then just like print out the
values does this makes sense like but
then go too
fast I see confused faces I
see
yes oh this is a so we're trying to find
X
right um and the way that we find it is
by by doing
research oh I guess
yeah just oh sorry sorry sorry it's not
okay this is a B name convention we call
it X but it's actually it's actually B
so we're TR we're looking for like the
small the smallest value B here that
could like that and that's where we have
like B's here like the minus X that's B
is over here yeah okay we I'll go maybe
I'll go edit the solutions and actually
actually change it to to B because
otherwise it's a little bit
misleading yeah yeah because like we
can't really train on that yes so how do
you like know that it's a grid search
approach and like would there be like
another way to solve it if you like
didn't get to that or
there probably there most likely is
another way to do it but I so I didn't
peruse the solutions for this particular
problem but the thing that tips it off
that is a grid search is here like we
want B rounded to two decimal places so
typically if you wants be rounded to
something places in a code and it's like
approximate it might just it usually
means like okay like I want to like
increment it slowly
somehow and that's typically like
research like okay I have a boundary on
the left I I have a boundary on the
right I'm going to just increment until
it's
done sometimes we like even provide a
range like here we didn't actually
provide a range like we just said okay
well true just make just find find a
region of of B that will like actually
just satisfy this and we're kind of guar
we're going to pretend that we're
guaranteed that this will terminate like
in all like in in in real life like this
whole like while true Loop might
actually never break because the
probability could it's possible that
that the probability is never like well
actually no no it will break because
eventually this will become eventually X
will become so big that it becomes
one yeah
okay yes we're actually moving the range
this way oh yeah we're expanding the
range yeah yeah so at some point like
the the thing is we're after like the
smallest value of B right and then at
some point we're going to get B so big
it's going to be one but then we don't
want that b one the smallest one such as
like greater than .95
yep okay yeah we want like tightness of
like lower
bound
okay I think okay so I think that was
the last question that was the last
example that I
had okay and yeah so I I was I saved
like the last like 15 or 20 minutes for
just like general questions about like
the final exam or for like parts of 109
we can also revisit the slides if people
have have questions about that but other
than than that like yeah that's all
that's all the material I had I had yes
yeah so on one of the practice finals it
had the question about like deep
learning networks and some math about
that but then on the like final
like like on the website it says like
don't you're not going to be expected to
do like deep neural networks so yeah
like is there just not going to be any
deep neural networks only up to like
logistic regression or even if we give
it to you the we'll make it we'll like
make a kind of of we'll make it
reasonable so we're not going to be
expecting you to take like vector
gradients or anything like that like
like we'll like we'll make it so that
it's doable with the stuff that we'
covered so in a problem like that
particular final what likely happened
was so in past iterations of 109 we used
to have like derivatives where like like
we could like people have like it's
actually possible to be like okay find
the gradient of like some like the of
like the of like the log likelihood
right or do like what's the part what's
the partial log likelihood with like
respect to like some like array of like
A's right and that's probably going to
be something like I don't know like
xrose something right we never did that
in class we're not don't worry about it
we will not give you this in in the exam
the even if you have a neuron network
with multiple nodes um we will prob it
will probably be like solvable just
using partial derivatives on different
on like each one of the elements of like
whatever like small Network we we
give
okay yeah all right uh any if any other
questions if not we can like well people
we can have uh 20 20 or so minutes back
and good luck on a
[Applause]
final